je m'appelle guide encore cinq minutes
on est la première famille du monde les
croûtes
c'est vrai encore être une belle journée
pape a dit que la meute doit toujours
rester groupés avant ma fille on cherche
l'endroit idéal pour s'installer
parce que cette poule c'est la fin du
monde
et cette fois c'est fini tu aurais pas
un petit creux basterds
[Musique]
ce curieux comme toutes ces plantes
comestibles sont parfaitement aliot
génial je croyais qu'il n'y avait plus
d'hommes des cavernes pour nous grand
plaisir rencontré fu
merci aux îles sont annulées des dom à
normale autrement dit les meilleurs
c'est la qualité et spacieux
salut c'est une fille oui une autre
je ne sais pas si les hommes des
cavernes ont leur place dans le monde
moderne
tu as un problème aux grands cet endroit
alors à tourner la tête
il faut qu'on limite le temps de
fenêtres de tincques nom de place et on
peut y aller 60e montant les regardais
pas on les chasse et je fais ce que je
mène ma vie c'est quoi une cicatrice
chaque marque raconte une aventure
mon père sait même pas que je me suis
fait ça au petit orteil cacahouète
a pas le droit de sortir banon alors
cette ferme c'est un peu ta caverne quoi
tu es comme moi
là on est hors faire une promenade
pourquoi ses parents ont construit ce
marathon éviter
sans mal
si on veut survivre la meute doit rester
groupés
tellement dangereux moi aussi je me fais
du souci pour ma famille
qu'est ce que c'est que ça certes le
d'attac
je me tenais journée pour mourir allez
vous depuis de raisons mais ce que je
trouve
pardon chérie tu as pris pour un
prédateurs affamés vous excuser jamais
d'avoir formé le cercle d'attributs si
tu portes un paresseux
je me sépare jamais dit mieux c'est trop
pratique hostile goulamas